doofe woche für markus söder sie wissen
ja der hatte doch diese knaller idee
kreuz pflicht für bayerische behörden so
eine schöne idee
und jetzt regen sich alle furchtbar auf
sogar die kirchen regen sich auf da ist
es man dürfe das kreuz nicht zu
wahlkampfzwecken missbrauchen
in seiner wut ist der söder diese woche
mit seinem kompletten hofstaat plus
blasorchester nach brüssel gefahren und
hat dort vor der bayerischen vertretung
ein riesiges kreuz aufgestellt
mai beschuldigung der maibaum ist die
bayerische tradition
wir stehen hier in brüssel was bedeutet
ist keine ahnung ist mir auch egal
das bedeutet dass du zu viel
tagesfreizeit hast man muss eigentlich
beten dass er im herbst die absolute
mehrheit kriegt sonst geht das pr
gewitter in eigener sache ja ewig weiter
inzwischen ist er schon ein fall für die
wissenschaft und für dietmar wischmeyer
herrschaft in ruhe bitte in unserer
vorlesungsreihe populistisches
angewandte stelle ich ihnen ein ganz
neues werk vor
das sei eine besonders im alpenraum
erfolgreiche verhaltensstörung benannt
nach dem fränkischen scheinriesen markus
maximus söder ein direkter nachbar des
sylter saures rex getreu dem bayerischen
motto lassen sie mich durch ich bin der
geilste gelang es dem gebirgs
kampfschwimmer geistiger flach gewässer
die staatskanzlei zu erobern nicht
mittels korbleger wahl sondern durch
heiligsprechung vorgenommen durch den
eigens zu diesem zwecke aufgetauten rc
stoiber achten sie bitte hier auf das
flüchtige grinsen mit dem der junge
monarch den schleim vorgang huldvoll
entgegennimmt
ja
den stärksten gestaltungs und
machtwillen und ist sicherlich nichts
was er nicht richtig macht und wir sehen
das schon aber opa hat halt seine brille
in brüssel liegen lassen um seine wahl
volk mit identitäten wandschmuck zu
erfreuen ließ dass söder nun vor jeder
amtsstube ein kreuz nageln damit den
muselmanen schon beim betreten der
kfz-zulassungsstelle eine heidenangst
unter den kaftan fährt doch oh graus
plötzlich geht den katholischen
bischöfen das kreuz als rein religiöses
symbol und nicht als zeichen der
ausgrenzung dürfe was wissen die schon
vom christentum welcher verrat an der
abendländischen tradition der kreuzzüge
aber wenn der söhne im herbst die
absolute mehrheit dann gelten dem
freistaat endlich wieder die wahren
werte übrigens liebe studenten
falls ihr mal zu gute laune haben
empfehle ich so dass youtube kanal wo
jeden tag botschaften in die schluchten
seines reiches hinauszögert und zwar
neuerdings immer auf einem alten blauen
sofa das noch franz josef strauß
persönlich durchgeführt hat bayern sind
einfach besser sein als andere
made in bavaria ist digital da möchte
ich dass bayern fordert dass das beste
für bayern
wir wollen es modernste land in europa
werden bayern soll weiter erfolgreich
sein bayerisch zu bleiben und diese
dinge wollen wir besprechen wollen wir
nicht wir wollen nur noch kotzen und
unser thema nächster woche lautet wie
mache ich mich selbst zum abgas affen
dann geht es um andreas scheuer minister
für ungeschützten verkehr und digitale
nach frisur
vielen dank
[Applaus]